so I'm filming this part this this right
here near the end of February I started
editing this video together so I wanted
to get it to you earlier than later on
in March and I thought I filmed an intro
to this month but I guess I didn't so
rather than just starting the journal I
wanted to give an intro but I also
wanted to give you a thank you whenever
I do something new it always makes me
nervous so I didn't know if you guys
would like seeing some journal things
journal vlog whatever it is of mine
behind the scenes my life my life
generally isn't that interesting you'll
probably see it more in this month's
video because there's no MORTAL KOMBAT
trip but you know but thank you thank
you for appreciating it and finding me
kind of interesting enough to stick
around through something like this but
also do the transition danger so in the
Captain Marvel trailers she stands up in
every trailer a lot so I it just made me
think of Slim Shady and stand up and I
cut a video together it's like 24
seconds long I think we're probably
better suited on Instagram but I just
want to put on YouTube just cuz I think
it's funny
Vanessa and I have a bet Vanessa says
everyone's gonna laugh hysterically at
it I think there are people who laugh a
sterically a lot of people are gonna be
like why the [ __ ] cuz us on this channel
but we'll say there's also a dad's root
beer behind me maybe that's why I did it
what's the bet what if you win doctor
buy you more desert beer and if I win I
get to buy you more desert beer okay I
hope they like it
having fun what percentage of dislikes
they come from movie reviews and they
get something else I like doing
different fun and goofy things so I want
to do it three percent I say thirty
twenty five so he's got a copyright
claim I put it up like three minutes ago
not big one
oh man the point was I didn't want ads
on there now there will be nothing I can
say about it it's their [ __ ] it's their
music damn that's why I can't do fun
stuff so it's been a busy couple days a
few days it's a third right yeah so
third but I came downstairs and I had
breakfast and a latte a 1.5 million
subscribers and Vanessa made me
breakfast and give me a little
celebration and sister [ __ ] yeah it was
really cool I have to show this to you I
would have shown it to you then but I
was kind of experiencing the moment but
the MS deflating and it's becoming M or
M so dangerous been licking his paw so
we're at the vet and he's getting his
paw hairs clip why do lights go out when
I do this do you think his path bears
clipped it's getting a new cone some
meds day in the life
also it's been a couple days since I
uploaded my Slim Shady
Captain Marvel mix I guess just making
fun of the trailer essentially but I
didn't think people would like it and
people liked it so thank you uh-huh it's
just like it wouldn't it's like I'll do
this goofy thing people were like no
that was a cool goofy thing makes you
want to do more goofy things you know
watching Deal or No Deal some
commercials nasty migraines I got to
finish editing the January journal vlog
thing ironically now you're seeing this
in probably March this is the beginning
of February time how am I supposed to
edit a video in the face of greatness
I'm still editing my January Journal and
of course I got a [ __ ] migraine it's
really dry and cold so every time I put
my dogs I shocked them for they shocked
me I don't know which one
dangers trying to it just ear and he has
a cone on so it can't it's the kind of
[ __ ] show did i oh
tim has sapped his nose oh but the ears
never spend a [ __ ] ton of time editing
something that's really long like this
January Journal thing then have your
editing software just closed and you
didn't save it it's not all gone but
like a quarter of it is if I smoked I
would take a smoke break I don't so I
just have to sit here and [ __ ] take
it
don't tell me what these selfie car
angles are the worst angles but so today
I'm gonna see therapist yes I see a
therapist
and this isn't sponsored by chat therapy
roulette or website or anything like
that I just it's healthy that they see a
therapist it you know just talk about
things it's essentially it's like
maintenance
it's like mental maintenance like
getting your oil changed in your car or
anything like that it's just good to
just keep up on it it's it's kind of
like a house where if you keep up on the
little projects you don't have to do the
big overhaul projects much later on so I
just think it's healthy and there's
always there's always something to talk
about I sigh see the therapist every
couple weeks or so and yeah well this
way the guys where else can you find
someone who wants to talk with you for
an hour someone you pay that's who
so therapy went good so but fun day yes
I am in a robe I'm in my pajamas right
now because I actually forgot a couple
days ago I totally forgot about the
session and I was like oh [ __ ] she was
like oh do you want to come in on
Thursday at 10:00 a.m. and it was like
oh well I'm gonna wear my pajamas
it so she's like that's cool so I did so
having a therapist with a sense of humor
not saying everybody needs it but I
certainly do so I put the January vlog
up and reading the comments I was just
nervous about it because I feel like
things like this and maybe it'll become
reality now that I mention it things
like this you never want to have
headphones in a bowl in your frame I
always feel like people like the the
illusion of things you know the more you
know about someone or something - listen
trigging it is and so personal life I'm
always nervous showing it but you guys
seem to like it and I really like that
thank you for that because it's no
there's no construction someone actually
commented like that's also been fun to
make it's like I just it's me going
through life and just putting my phone
on and while it's happening so I know
and Tufts of fur on the floor I need to
vacuum the floor danger but I'm not
going to I'm trying to be healthy we
gotta eat healthy and we're gonna start
tomorrow cuz leftover nachos are way too
good just a day in the life
two dogs and Deal or No Deal
oh nice taste buddy let's throw the
penguin [ __ ] someone suggested the name
of this this vlog this journal series as
I like to call I like to call it a
journal essentially not a vlog but
someone suggested the hashtag Jon's vlog
which is funny so that's a Captain's Log
I can't
god I can't not do that in some capacity
Captain's Log supplemental
we're going to the neutral zone wheel Oh
will you ready for command how are you
today number one eye counselor troi
playing parisi squares again are we with
number one someone said in the comment
section ships he looks sad she totally
does she has the Sarah McLachlan eyes
like in the but she really is happy
danger learned how to lick his paw even
with the cone on what's the point of
cones danger danger stop you're gonna
hurt your paw more buddy oh well holy
[ __ ] these socks are different that's to
find out at the end of the day whatever
so editing my review for what men want
and I make the point that the characters
in her office are like super exaggerated
douche bag types I try to illustrate I
know what they're doing with it they're
making an exaggeration to make a point
but I feel like I'm gonna run into a lot
of [ __ ] like I feel like you
misogynistic [ __ ] who knows we'll see
how is Seth gecko DUP like George
Clooney's greatest role the abominable
snow puppies when I was a kid and maybe
it's because I watched the movie the day
after which [ __ ] me up but snow coming
from the sky looks gray with the
contrast against the clouds so it looks
like nuclear fallout I don't know that
I'm [ __ ] out so I'm making coffee as I
say this so my review of what men want
went up and I called weed selling Voodoo
lady weed selling voodoo lady
because in the movie weed selling voodoo
lady is in fact weed selling voodoo lady
I've been informed that is musical
legend Erykah Badu or Badu one of the
two they were like you need some [ __ ]
culture and they're probably right I
probably do my point is you can't be
versed with all the legends in the world
I know video game performers and classic
rock people but even not all the classic
rock people don't even all the ac/dc
songs Vanessa is probably not coming
over today she's like I'll stay at home
so it's going to be a day of retro video
games music TV shows fuzz on my face
oh no that's not fun whoo oh man here I
can't gather the Peter watch to leave
Neeson movie that I have rear-wheel
drive
I won't make it down the hill so I'm
trapped here it is the apocalypse
Simon and Garfunkel's greatest hits
there's gotta be it's such a good album
with a range of emotion this is an
emotional album so when danger runs in
the snow he sniffs the snow which makes
the cone scrape it up like a shovel and
then it gets in his face okay
Fire Emblem the sacred stones for the
Game Boy Advance has an epic story and
if you haven't played it yet you should
wanna see how gypsy in danger deal with
the snow this deep I know Jeb's she's
gonna brave it I know I don't have a
snow shovel so I'm gonna take this big
obscure board and I'm gonna use it to
carve a path for my dog so they can pay
and poo in my yard you gotta get inside
inside they're carving pads it's been
nine centuries since the legend of the
frost sausage with a fire we will warm
up the puppies all right the snows
[ __ ] crazy so we gotta get into
survival mode this is what happens when
you live on your own the most ration
cien dish in the hockey gypsy oh okay
gypsy you want food chips you want to
play in the snow gypsy are you okay it's
such a cat gypsy I won't tell vanessi
your butt was on her bailout so that's
me
that's gypsy and that's danger and
that's pretty much the stability of my
house I will say this whole monthly
journal vlog thing will force me to
vacuumed my carpet more often than I do
air my crooked vacuum lines
so among the mountain of
madness had to shovel the driveway to
get Vanessa in but it does we're in
Washington we're not prepared for this
kind of [ __ ] I will say is danger loud
dangerous she wants me to throw the
thing he's already killed nobody it's
going to even believe that I just
shoveled that [ __ ] in my pajama bottoms
and Animaniacs t-shirt look I didn't
even do it to posture like I'm tough I
just did it because I thought it would
be a quick job now I'm huddled next to
the fire fetch with sausage achlys good
job buddy isn't her frostbite repair and
also danger wants us to throw the ball
so gypsy acts like she can't jump up
until you act like you're going to pick
her up it was like okay oh yes II didn't
even touch her she jumps right up
because he wants to know who's running
the show no she took dangers bang oh I'm
taking this back okay so this is Anna
Kendrick or Amy Adams or I love fish or
Pam Beesly which is funny because I yeah
Amy Adams actually Rob Burnett Robert
Meyer Burnett was the first one to say
like oh she reminds me of Amy Adams like
holy [ __ ] she kind of doesn't think
updater I know I just think you're
pretty
so is blurry and I can't make it focus
well not actually hold on there's a
there's a feeling there's your dadgum
function on here do i impress you when
you come over and I look like [ __ ] in a
beanie and that Animaniacs t-shirt and
you're like [ __ ] you
guy I know she's just gonna lose [ __ ]
whenever this tug O'War it's so fun to
do is dangerous all right yeah she looks
like a PEZ dispenser Oh oh crap he got
it from me that means he established his
dominance which means I've lost control
forever I lost it years ago we're now
venturing out into Snowmageddon the
snowpocalypse you know nothing Jon Snow
McGann what am I trying to say now I
think we're gonna die of dysentery I
know can you shoot one bison and take
120 thirds of meat because that's really
what architrave although so we've been
trying to take a picture of us that's
all cute forever and every one of them's
[ __ ] blurry cuz I suck at this every
time we're here I have to look at the
electronics section games movie how will
we survive the apocalypse the pizza is
more empty than the aygos which means
only one thing the Ninja Turtles have
raided target and the bread cops
[Music]
Vanessa had an idea what was your idea
okay so please are assorting good donuts
myth donuts so we take two take two of
these also notice we tell the internet
and we get arrested later that's so
dishonest so good tickets to donut Jail
you remember bail at IKEA jail we walked
against there I mean it's in the
PlayStation I show you how are we to
survive
there's no video proof of the assault
there's only one reason fine all right
you got there that really backfired
didn't it people it wasn't exactly how I
saw that going
stop being a lot funnier I saw snowball
flying at ya run I'm running on us she
wouldn't know it right by me to me
they'll never believe
so we just have a snowball fight and I
totally thought I was recording now I
have a frozen hand Internet we'll never
know Wow only thing is danger just wants
me to fetch ugly puppy sweaters thank
you
the last puzzle was so fun we're gonna
do another puzzle we have Star Wars and
ice cream cats we're gonna do ice cream
cats first then Star Wars one day well
crank this thing on no problem but here
is puzzle round two I think people need
to know the truth that these side pieces
don't exist and we totally got [ __ ]
hey what are you doing get mind a jerk
come on buddy quick quick just snow date
you whoever decided to put egg on a
burger is a genius it's the greatest
burger this like the Resident Evil 2
burger right there slides right off the
book we're not proud man who will rewind
the [ __ ] out of Mega Man just tripping
me out Oh God so gypsy gets super
anxiety when I leave should we go to
this Thunder jacket would makes you look
like a little cigarette you look a
little burrito gypsy you were the cutest
version of the thing on Star Trek 4 that
was talking to the whales ok so but this
is all for science I know this was very
dog centric the last couple days but
usually when tug of wars happening she's
losing her [ __ ] she's not losing her
[ __ ] right now it's so fun to do is
dangerous all right it's like the
thunder'd shirt is like a magical tree
this is not sponsored by I just I'm
actually really pumped that jib
just kind of chill right now meanwhile
dangerous like hey this cone isn't doing
[ __ ] for me I hate it okay so as the
night went on it's about 2:00 a.m. now
and I wasn't gonna do a video in the
Aladdin trailer then I watched it a
couple more times then I was like
there's enough here to talk about
because the trailer doesn't suck because
of Will Smith Genie CGI it sucks because
of nearly everything including but not
limited to Will Smith Genie CGI so I
don't want to make a video just talking
[ __ ] but that's that's the best they got
this was cleared out so I've thoroughly
bitched about the Aladdin trailer and
now we're gonna walk in the snow cuz
they're supposed to rain and then snow
and then snow and then rain and it was
gonna snow for 10 days straight and then
it was gonna rain for 7 days straight
now it's gonna snow and possibly the
point is the weather they don't know
what's happening people in really cold
states like Montana and the last guy I
know we in Washington are making a very
big deal about this but we really don't
get this kind of stuff dangerous cone
sniffing my code that I'm trying to get
dry by the fireplace because it's wet
because the snow is really wet why don't
you enjoy some orange juice seems like a
good idea seemed like a good idea I love
orange juice totally you just skip my
mind that I just brushed my teeth it
didn't taste great feel like the more
you do it the more battle go away we're
used to it I don't know
see I think that was better than the
first time okay a lot of people have
asked other oh my god I just vacuumed
this floor hi danger a lot of people
have that's the difference between gypsy
and dangerous so first and foremost
gypsy is the princess sleeping gypsy oh
there she is all right so gypsy is the
princess but yes pinstripe little
freckles freckles her ears are usually
down there first more smooth and
well-groomed because she's a lady yeah
prioritize her beauty over everything
basically this short for danger is the
attention hog danger and her perfect
symmetrical dumb head perfect high
danger
we're not playing fetch right now and
now she wants to fetch so I'm gonna hold
this above the phone so he sits and acts
like he's paying attention so danger his
fur looks like he's been shocked with
static electricity 90% of the time he
has the thicker stripe which I always
joke about Star Wolf being his dad
because they have the same stripe in his
ears are up a little more than hers even
when he's not wearing a cone and so
right now he's a conehead so they are
gonna fight crime as the adventures of
cone and dome oh there are mini
Australian Shepherds I said I think
they're toy Australian Shepherds I was
told they were gonna be minis but
they're smaller those are smaller than
minis so yeah they're about 14 pounds so
I'm gonna say toy Australian Shepherds
though I do call them minis a lot of the
time and they are cute and they know it
and they both really want me to throw
this thing most of the personalities are
really different like he's kind of its
neurotic he's really sweet he's but he
is he's energetic he's more energetic
than she is she's more chill than him
case in point super chill in my face you
saw what's going on Tina yeah no there's
a Halloween cat for sure
you have Tufts of fur on your ground on
your floor this is literally the saddest
[ __ ] thing God it's for you it's for
the betterment of you it doesn't sound
as sad as it is stopp'd they really are
fine all right I'll be honest with you
guys I took this really cute picture of
the cats after their trials and
tribulations after the hardest car ride
ever seen two cats go through yeah yeah
it was the most heartbreaking 30 minutes
of our lives by that I took this really
cute picture of them and they're snuggly
and their friends and when I put the
phone down I swear to you they proceeded
to beat the living [ __ ] out of each
other
who knew you did I just thought they
there's nothing in Ramsey's eyes or says
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you kita
like in that picture so we're watching
Shane Dawson's conspiracy theory and we
got to the part where your phone makes
noise because it's like supposedly
zapped and like it might be placebo
effect but I almost swear I hear
something so I'm going to record the
sound and then put it on editing
software I put headphones on jack up the
sound and the volume damn it Shane so
I'm kind of bummed I can't hear anything
that or they heard that I was gonna try
to hear something and so they stopped
recording sad I wanted early crack the
case white [ __ ] open yeah what a few
minutes yeah a few minutes of setup and
getting my phone and putting it in the
closet under the stairs where it's
silent and then recording it twice
because I kind of felt like I made too
much noise the first time getting my
headphones and turn
but it was a whole thing it only took
like a minute vanity it's definitely my
favorite said a little bit just a crap
in the corner of the room
yes vanessa is moving in here hence the
pacat drama and the things out of place
and really vain cats that look at their
reflection there's full moving day and
because it's no-pocalypse I missed the
screening too happy deathday to you so
after moving day
I got a watch happy deathday to you it's
dead if I had to pick one I would choose
happy deathday to you over moving I'm
not moving from my place vanessa is
moving into here I have more [ __ ] than
she has I think I'm gonna die in this
place move in the bed so in this move
because there's no place to park a
u-haul and move except the place that
you're not supposed to park so the city
came up to us and they were like we need
you to move and I was like I can't how
much is decided they're like we're going
out to site yeah I was like how much
does a citation like 35 is like dollars
yeah my name is Jeremy just make it out
to me something good so I'm getting a
$35 citation were sit this is a really
cool though they were like we get it a
couple of young guys like it really does
the same thing so you guys if you're
watching our rad and I hope the city
enjoys the 35 bucks they can go to the
movies once and buy one popcorn that's
about the price sidenote [ __ ] couch
parts we've hit the point in the movie
for everyone's cranky oh it's like
someone just moved in or something and
you know it looks like a hoarder
oh man I don't think we should clean it
all things you live it I think it's a
good idea right and cacti so much cat
you know serial killers have cacti I'm
taking more video
really oh man yeah kind of I look like I
could be laying down peacefully I feel
like my body's breaking like like my
knees hurt is that part of it
what did that start happening I I retire
from helping people move yeah can this
be motivation like to not break up hey I
know I'm difficult to do that all over
again
you know let's work it out this is us so
happy deathday to you it's not happening
tonight
I'm just to [ __ ] be I'm too tired so
I can review it watch it and we're here
tomorrow Thursday right
yeah so that's like a day after it came
out and people still might give a [ __ ]
they were humped but better late than
never but I if I even do it tonight I'll
I won't even remember what I saw so so
among I mean the place is pretty
disastrous still but we are bombing it
today bad we're just like so this is
Vanessa's couch and it's awesome and
it's modern and it's nice and I'm not
saying I have buffalo chicken pizza but
I'm scared to eat this on there because
I don't want her to break up with me
because I don't want to have to move all
this [ __ ] again and because you're
adorable and I look you know what that's
the thing is I love you but I also like
you and those are two very different
things but I both you but also [ __ ]
eating this there okay so making a
judgment call here I'm going to split
February's journal into two parts
because the February's
to be a slow month like there's no
Mortal Kombat trip it'll be short
no it's twice as long as the January one
I don't necessarily want to cut anything
out so I'm going to split February into
two this was part one I'll get you part
two later this week weekend maybe next
week but it'll be coming soon so once
again thank you for enjoying the
journals and I'll bring you part 2 soon
gypsy you want to do the fade here for
the state never mind
[Music]